here is a question for you sidetrack in  Stargate there are lots and lots of  humans scattered around the Galaxy  because they were all taken from Earth  from Egypt  but they all look very very human do you  think if a new series of Stargate comes  out we'll see more variations of  different styles of human maybe they  have pointy ears like Spock maybe  they'll have little lines on their head  like the guy from I don't know what that  guy is but whatever his name is  maybe there'll be blue because of like  the weird atmospheres on their Planet  what do you think will we see more  variations  or is it just gonna be more of the same  More Humans  let me know